hello everyone and welcome to the long
awaited game three of the World Chess
Championship match between yaniponishi
and English and I say the long-awaited
as we uh had a rest today every two days
of play we have one rest day so we have
to wait a bit longer for the World Tour
Championship Match to continue but now
it resumes and it was uh in my opinion
quite action-packed as you'll see once I
present the game but before that uh here
is uh uh who made the first ceremonial
move uh it is um as they called him on
the uh fida's official Twitter page the
people's hero of Kazakhstan uh the
astronaut talgat Musa have making the
first ceremonial move for the third game
uh the former Cosmonaut musabai flu and
three space flights including two long
duration stays aboard the space station
mirror uh his third space flight was a
short duration visit uh mission to the
International Space Station which
carried the first paying space tourist
he is now the head of cast Cosmos
kazakhstan's National Space Agency so
there you have it making the first first
move uh you you can't really tell much
about the players and nip obviously
being very happy he's leading the match
and the ding I think he can't wait to
see what will happen on the board will
it be the same as in game one if you
remember in game one uh Jan opened with
E4 and we had that um a very tricky line
of the rule Lopez but here uh already we
have a switch in the first move young
plays Pawn to D4 and now ding has to
really think on how to how to prepare
for this of course uh players are
prepared for both the D4 and um E4 as
those are the most standard moves you
can make in chess but still probably one
was expecting E4 here as Jan had a very
promising position in game one so okay
Knight to F6 by then we have Pawn to C4
E6 and not Knight the C3 probably Jan
was thinking the ding would go for the
names of Indian with Bishop to B4 but he
doesn't ding just replies with D5 and we
have the standard Queen's Gambit
declined and now probably believe nipple
went for something like Knight to F3 we
would see that our goals in defense but
nepo goes for a trade in the center C
characters on D5 with e captures on D5
and now Bishop to G5 the so-called
positional line and now Pawn to C6 uh we
have E3 uh by Nepal uh Ponte H6 Bishop
page for end Bishop to E7 so all very
nicely played uh D3 uh Bishop to D3 and
King side castles biting and it's a very
standard position uh for example Magnus
Carlsen uh plays played this against
white many many times he had uh this
position against uh Felucia he had
against uh some other players as well or
rather he had it three times against
firuja uh he won uh one uh one game and
he drew the other two games and also uh
Magnus had this position with black
against Parham aksulu the the game and
they didn't draw so it is a fairly
fairly playable position Queen to C2 and
now we have Rook the EA there was a lot
of discussion about this position uh as
there often is when the bishop is still
on C8 in the Queen is on C2 imagine if
black plays something like Knight to the
E8 you might imagine Bishop captures on
E7 Queen characters and now Knight
captures on D5 and it seems like okay
now obviously this is not good for white
because after C captures on D5 there's
Queen captures and C8 but all of a
sudden Knight to C6 and what is
happening here it's it's a full Rook
sacrifice and if Queen captures Rook
here
uh then Queen to B4 with check and white
will already have problems playing this
game for example King to F1 not Knight
the F6 and the queen is trapped or
rather you have to pick up the second
Rook Queen characters King characters
and now you continue playing this uh but
with the white king and F1 uh with the
Knight and Rook still needing to find a
way into the game uh black will have a
better game here but it's not really a
problem all this can be averted because
after this queen captures an E7 and uh
Knight captures on D5 uh you don't have
to go for this you can just continue
with Knight to F3 and okay nothing
special is happening here so that's why
uh we we don't see this uh funny nights
they climb we just have Rook d8 by ding
just keeping the tension Knight G2 E2 uh
the the pretty standard maneuver uh in
the future we want to play F3 and D4
that's one plan and the other one is uh
pulling off some sort of a minority
attack with A4 and B4 so Knight b37 we
have castles and now Pawn to A5 stopping
B4 as this is one of white
um most common plants with A3 and now
Knight the H5 ding now offers a trade of
Bishops with Bishop captures King
characters and now you have to decide on
how to continue this game uh most often
a rook 831 is played now the funny thing
is uh the England already had this
position in the adjustable Masters 2022
against none other than Anish giri and
Anisha shared his thoughts on this
position because he has analyzed it
quite a lot
uh he said that the engine sometimes
says that you should go Rook to B1 and
then whatever black plays you should
move the Rook D1 or play Rook to C1 and
then once black makes a move put the
Rook the E1 like the engine makes some
very weird suggestions in this position
so it's very hard to actually listen to
the engine here one of them is the best
of th7 check once the king moves just
Bishop to back to D3 which is sort of uh
giving blank the move uh uh for uh for
for having his King on hatred instead of
on G8 so also very weird stuff uh Plus
on the other hand black can just repeat
King to G8 if black wants to uh but okay
uh here Rook 81 following the game Anish
played against ding in adjustable
masters with Knight to f8 now and Knight
the C1 sorry Knight to C1 the Knight now
wants to come to B3 and then to C5 to
put pressure on on Black's Queen side
and now we have Knight to F6 you could
consider some other moves but dink
continues um the way he played against a
niche in the adjustable Masters uh and
now we have F3 again you could decide
for something like Knight to B3 let's
say Knight to E6 now and now Knight the
D Doom this is a way of Shifting the
Knight back to F3 to control the D4 Pawn
so you can execute E4 at some point and
also to just keep the D4 Pawn defended
for example now C5 you can play Knight
to F3 and the D4 Pawn is nicely defended
captures captures and the game continues
uh but instead after this Knight to F6
more we have Pawn to F3 makes sense you
uh want to push E4 and you have plans of
defending the D4 Pawn perhaps with Queen
to F2 so the queen defends the D4 Pawn
once E4 is played but here we have
Knight to E6 and now this situation on
the clock is a minute an hour and 38
minutes for Nepal and an hour and 10
minutes for ding so nepo are definitely
up on the clock and now uh it's a hard
to uh really continue this game like I
said in the game Anish versus Dean Queen
to F2 was played that the game ended in
a draw uh but although some of the moves
you really want to make don't make sense
for example King to H1
uh is the move you want to play getting
the King off of this diagonal uh the
problem is it runs into a tactic Knight
captures on the four end you have
problems here for example captures
you're gonna capture with the queen Rook
characters real characters with check
and this now ends in Checkmate after
Bishop to F1 and Rook captures on F1 so
that doesn't work another thing that you
might consider is Bishop to F5 okay uh
let's uh just uh put pressure on this
Knight that's attacking our D4 Pawn so
we can capture it maybe on push E4 the
problem is here Knight captures and D4
also works and now it's just a pure uh
pure uh sort of a queen sacrifice not
really a queen sacrifice giving up the
queen for lots of material Queen
captures anyone Rook captures and Rook
captures with check and now after King
to F2 it seems that black really has
nothing here there's Bishop captures on
F5 and after Queen captures an F5 now
you're just gonna play Rook captures and
C1 and black has uh uh well a fair
amount of compensation for the queen two
Rooks and the pawn
uh should be very nice for black so
instead after this uh Knight to E6 move
we don't have any of these uh moves that
that we've discussed the bishop to F5 or
H3 here instead we have Knight one to E2
and it is now as of move 17 that we have
a completely new game and it took nepo
quite some time to figure this one out
because I think nepo was also
remembering this game that being played
against Danish and he thought that maybe
this was his actual plan uh what he
wanted to play against this but then he
figured that it doesn't really give you
all that much so because for example if
Queen to F2 you might imagine something
like Pawn to B5 and now it's very hard
to play if you now execute E4 let's say
d captures Knight captures all of a
sudden Rook to d8 now the D D4 Pawn is
uh under attack and if Knights they eat
you you can play Pawn to B4 and it's uh
well uh giving black maybe more than you
should Bishop to A6 coming next and so
on so that's why Ian played Knight one
to E2 and now we have Pawn to C5 by ding
uh just going after a white strong
Center here uh C5 is not mandatory by
any means you could play Rook to B8 to
prepare B5 you could play B5 right away
which also makes sense with an idea of
maybe B4 later on but okay uh C5 is the
move with Bishop to B5 now uh again many
moves you could consider here like you
could consider Queen to D2 as it simply
makes sense from a positional standpoint
because you know that Bishop to D7 and
Rook to see it are coming so the queen
will be under attack also a fine line to
consider is Knights the F4 now if Bishop
to D7 you can trade here let's say
Bishop capture spawn captures and you
will have this fine grip on the position
with Bishop to G6 now the other Rook has
to come to C8 and now you're gonna move
the queen pretty much the queen comes to
D2 in all the lines so you can play it
pretty much whenever let's say B5 and I
have the characters and C5 Queen
captures and C5 Knight to E2 and okay
now the Rooks may be coming to the C
file it's a fine position for both white
and black maybe the black position looks
a bit too weakened with only the G and H
Pawn guarding the black king but it's
very much playable however Nepal went
for Bishop to B5 and this move is a very
very tricky because uh ding really wants
to play Bishop to D7 so it kind of looks
like you've you're allowing him to play
Bishop to D7 with Tempo now the problem
is if you go Bishop to D7 here then look
at this bishop captures Queen captures
and now how do you continue this if D
captures on C5 then there are a lot of
uh tricky moves here let's say Knight
captures and C5 now Knights the D4 and
now Rook 8 the C8 putting pressure on
the queen here just Queen to D2 and it's
a very a very odd position uh the the
pretty much it's always the same thing
black has the the d-pawn white has the
backwards E3 pawn and perhaps the weak
B2 pawn and uh should be okay if you
play Perfect moves but you know only if
you play Perfect moves though also
there's the thing of after Bishop D7
that after Bishop captures and queen
captures you can go for this very very
tricky Knight to a form move and now it
seems like you're going after B6 which
is just winning material and also if you
stop this how are you stopping just
capturing a pawn here well you stop it
by playing C captures on D4 and this is
what black has and why this plan for
white Isn't So spectacular let's deny
the B6 attacks the queen and uh uh Rook
here Queen to D6 you can capture The
Rook but now D captures an E3 you grab
another pawn and of course the Knight
will be captured there's no um a way of
stopping that CC C7 squares covered by
the queen and by the Knight they're
gonna have to play Queen to B3 to
prepare the uh Rescue of the Knight but
also you're just going after the E3 pawn
and now if Rook captures an A8 Queen
will capture an E3 and now let's say
Pawn to D4 looks very very strong for
both white and black uh to be honest but
not Rook to D1 and it's a very very hard
to save uh if this D4 move uh does
anything let's say Knight to D5 attacks
the queen queen F2 now Knight D to F4 we
trade everything captures captures and
now uh you have this position where if
you capture on D4 then there's this very
nasty Knight to the E2 check so it seems
the black keeps the pawn uh and it's a
very very off uh offbeat position where
white is up the exchange but the black
has the past pawn and the Knight here so
uh maybe it's a bit too much a bit too
much of an active play to give to ding
uh but ding decides against that and
ding just keeps the pressure on the
board after Bishop to B5 he doesn't go
for Bishop to D7 he just plays Rook to
d8 and he says all right let's uh let's
play this um I'm not in rush to trade
any anything let's continue the game
uh D capitals and C5 by on Queen
captures on C5 and now Queen to D2 like
I said the move that should be played in
all the lines and now the question is
what does ding want to play here and he
can just claim a draw right away if he
plays D4 then we pretty much trade
everything let's say captures counters
captures captures captures and captures
and here let's say Rook the D1
characters counters and after this
fabulous capture Fest is over uh equal
material not much to look forward to
here it's uh let's say Bishop T6 it's
still still a draw uh however dingo's
Bishop to D7 he refrains from uh playing
D4 and he offers a trade of Bishops now
and nepo accepts this and this is uh
very very tricky uh what he probably
should have gone for is Knight to the D4
this sort of keeps the tension in the
game let's say Knights the E8 and now
after Rook to C1 putting pressure on the
queen just Knight captures on D4 he
captures Queen D6 and Bishop back to D3
uh keeps keeps the tension and the
position is fine for for both white and
black however after this is Bishop
captures on D7 move he thought that Ding
has to recapture with the Rook here but
didn't just played Knight captures on D7
and now what's up with the D5 D5 Pawn
Can you capture this no you can't
because if you capture with the queen
then Queen captures an E3 check and you
are uh in in problems here you do not
want to give up this E3 Pawn if anything
you want to keep it forever at some
point you want to play it the E4 if you
capture with the Knight then Knight the
B6 wins material here now there's no way
to save the knight uh and of course this
is impossible because uh well uh the
queen would deliver check to the to the
white king so instead after Knight
captures on D7 nepo played Knight to D4
and now we have Queen
uh sorry ignite the B6 now now it seems
that ding's Knight is coming to C4 and
it will put pressure on B2 the queen and
the E3 pawn and this is the I believe
first time in three games that nepo
became a little bit worried about the
outcome of this game because this is uh
uh there there's definitely a lot to
hold here and the situation on the clock
is one hour for nepo 47 minutes for ding
he played Rook to D1 and okay and any
move will be met with Knight to C4 so
it's it's merely a matter of uh keeping
an under D4 Knight Knight's the C4
attacks the queen and now Queen to F2
and here is the move that really uh I
think we're we're doing really wanted to
play Knight captures on A3 because it
sort of wins a clean Pawn if if you
capture ninjas Queen captures and C3 but
there's a problem what if Ponte E4 is
played and now how do you stop Punk
cappers on D5 is there any way to stop
this if you play Pawn captures here then
just Knight captures on e4 and now the
queen is at attack the Knight is no
longer on C3 and now B captures an A3
will just win a win a clean piece so you
can't allow this Knight to move from C3
with Tempo so you don't have that aside
from that after E4 you could play Knight
captures on D4 but it's not much better
Rook captures on D4 and not Knight to B5
uh the Knight now has to move you can't
allow the White Knight to move from C3
and now if Knight captures Queen
captures just Rook after D1 and this is
how uh White uh uh retains material
equality uh there's no way to actually
save the D5 Pawn so after Queen a queen
to F2 uh while Knights captures on A3 is
a move you want to play
uh Dean plays Rook a to C8 which if you
give the engine enough time it is the
first line of the engine so Dean
calculates properly and okay nipple very
happy Knight's day 4 attacks the black
queen we have Queen back to E7 and now
Rook after E1 as this is a problematic
Pawn you wanna have it sufficiently
defended and now Queen to F6 biting and
ding pretty much played all of his moves
instantly here another move to consider
is Knight cap for sun D4 I will just
show it because it's a lot of fun now
ecaptress is possible Rook captures is a
little bit better because D5 also is a
little bit weak for example B5 attacks
the Knight the knights the C3 and now
Queen to C5 with B4 planned uh maybe not
not a terrible option for ding but
instead ding went for Queen to F6 and
now comes Knight to B5 by Nepal and now
the situation on the clock is 41 minutes
nipple 31 minutes for Ding and here ding
went into a deep thing and played Knight
to C7 which is definitely the way to go
it is the top move recommended by the
engine and and the Nepal might even be
uh you know prompted into trading
because he could be a little bit worried
here the problem is if he trades let's
say Knight captures on C7 and Rook
captures uh there are all sorts of lines
to consider here most of them favoring
black uh like one of them okay you could
just play Rook to D3 in hopes of maybe
doubling up on the D file but look at
this if you go Knight to C3 let's say
you try a little tactics uh and now
let's say Knight captures on B2 uh
Knight captures on D5 and now Queen to
A5 let's say something like this happens
uh the problem is here you have Queen to
G3 and white just wins uh there's no way
to uh to to avoid this because now after
Rook captures on D5 which is your top
move group captures uh there's Just Wing
captures and D5 and queen captures on C7
so white will be of the exchange and
even if you don't trade uh even if you
just trade on G3 white will still be up
the The Exchange two Rooks against the
rook and the Knight the problem is after
Knight capture 7 D5 you don't have to go
Queen E5 you can go Queen to G5 and now
it's pretty much we just trade
everything off Queen captures on B2 Rook
captures on D5 and after Rook after some
D5 Queen captures on D5 and now let's
say queen to D4 offers a queen trade but
just Queen to C6 and the problem is now
yes you've freed your E3 Pawn it's no
longer a backwards Pawn but you and you
will be able to play It's the E4 but
you've allowed black the two to one
advantage on the queen side thing we'll
put a rook on the B file play B5 B4
create a pass pawn and basically nipple
will have to defend for the rest of the
game so that's the problem with actually
trading on C7 so here nepo uh considered
the position for for some time he played
Knight back to D4 and now everyone
expected the ding to go for B5 it's the
move that he prepared it's the move that
he dreamed of for for the entire game
everyone thought B5 would be played here
and after Knight to C3 now just to Rook
the EA just keeping the tension putting
pressure on that backwards E3 pawn and
uh this Knight captain is uh well it is
an option it doesn't yield all that much
for example captures captures and
captures now Queen to B6 put pressure on
the Knight puts pressure on E3 uh also
with the Knight moves puts pressure on
B2 and now if Knights at the D4 you can
just trade here captures captures and
captures and if we're up to D2 you
always have this very nasty pressure
with a beautiful Knight on C4 putting
pressure on the a point putting pressure
on the backwards Z3 Pawn so it's it just
seems like it's much harder to play this
for why the engine of course assesses
this as a 0.00 but it just feels like it
should be easier to play with black
however to everyone's surprise ding did
not go for B5 ding actually repeated uh
Knight to E6 and here nippo said all
right are we actually doing this he
played Knight to B5 didn't Play the
knights the C7 the nipple played Knight
to D4 ding play Knights the E6 and it
was in this position that the players
agreed to a draw or rather it's a draw
by threefold repetition on move 30 as
you know it's impossible possible to
offer a draw before move 40 those are
the official rules of the world cheers
championship match but if it's a draw by
threefold repetition then it's just a
draw
uh so very very nice game uh I I don't
feel like nipple got all that much with
D4 as he got with E4 and it seemed like
both of them were really mixing up their
their preparation like both of them were
following the game Dingle already played
against Anish uh and then at some point
uh you know they just uh had to really
start calculating and the the this was
the end result so uh ding did get
something little out of the opening and
he could have maybe gotten a bit more
but uh you know he already lost the game
he doesn't want to over push it and beat
down two points in a in a worldshire
championship match but yeah it's gonna
be it's gonna be very interesting to see
what uh nepo and his team come up with
for game five with the white pieces
probably gonna be another E4 uh but you
never know nepo could have something
blindly let's play e4d for Knight to F3
and then C4 making it impossible for
ding to prepare for any game uh with the
white pieces and then I I also think
it's gonna be pretty impossible uh once
they repeat like they go into game nine
uh which opening will they choose so
that could be the plan it could be just
switching between E4 and D4 it could be
just seeing what does better and then
sticking with that so uh there's no idea
there's no way for us to know we'll just
have to see what happens but yeah a very
exciting game could have uh a lot could
have happened maybe maybe the the
position still could have been played uh
but the problem is the Players repeated
moves here and the repetition of moves
is in fact the strongest uh move by both
players uh in the given position
recommended by the engine so I mean
objectively they they played it like
like a computer uh so yeah that's the
game I hope you guys enjoyed it the
World Chess Championship game three
between animal and we'll see what
happens in game four and wielding
prepare something special for us with
the white pieces because what he brought
for game two although quite an
impressive surprise with that H3 move uh
it's it's very hard for me to imagine
that he will repeat that but maybe he
will so we we'll see what happens
tomorrow so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it uh probably I'd like
to thank yaroslav simbita I said Borgo
Matthew Benoit JB and James Cashman for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the World Chess Championship
Match uh until it finishes uh so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day